good evening I'm Stuart brand from long
now foundation I think Steven Pinker's
written the most important book in many
years
that's why he's here tonight and there's
a long now aspect to it which is that
many people get the sort of gist of the
book which is that violence cruelty and
injustice have been going down for quite
a while and the first response that many
people have is well wait a minute come
on there's civil wars going on I read in
the paper this morning there's rape over
here and murder over there and violence
in Libya or wherever and what you're
seeing there is something I hadn't
really thought about before reading this
book which is the long now foundation
has been helping deal with a common
social psychological concept which is
discounting the future we tend to put
all of the value into the present and
into the near future and discount the
long future in a way the long now and
building a 10,000 year clock is going to
keep ticking exactly the same for a
century after century millennium after
millennium into the future the idea is
to start taking the future with the same
kind of seriousness that we take next
week next 1,000 years next week same
thing well I think Pinker's book
demonstrates is that we also have a
tendency to discount the past and the
absolutely thala tea and cruelty that
humans used to inflict on each other
because it was long ago we don't take it
with the kind of serious seriousness
that we take what's going on right now
and Pinker going backward the same way
the 10,000 year clock going forward
helps us not discount the past Steven
Pinker
it's okay
[Music]
thank you very much believe it or not
and I know most people do not violence
has been in decline for long stretches
of time and today we may be living in
the most peaceful era in our species
existence the decline of violence has
not been steady it has not brought rates
of violence down to zero and it is not
guaranteed to continue but I hope to
persuade you that it is a persistent
historical development visible on scales
from millennia to years
from wars and genocides to the treatment
of children and animals I'm going to
walk you through six major declines of
violence identify their immediate causes
that is particular historical events of
the era and also try to tie them
together in terms of their ultimate
causes that is general historical forces
interacting with human nature the first
decline of violence I call the
pacification process until around 5,000
years ago humans everywhere lived in
Anarchy without central government what
was life like in this state of nature
this is a question that thinkers have
pondered for centuries
in 1651 Thomas Hobbes famously wrote
that in a state of nature the life of
man is solitary poor nasty brutish and
short a century later jean-jacques
rousseau countered that nothing can be
more gentle than man in his primitive
state now it turns out that these two
gentlemen were speculating from the
armchair neither of them had any idea
what life was like in a state of nature
but today we can do better because there
are two sources of evidence on rates of
violent death in non-state societies the
first is forensic archaeology you can
think of this as CSI Paleolithic namely
what proportion of prehistoric skeletons
have signs of violent trauma like bashed
in skulls decapitations arrowheads
embedded in bones and mummies found with
ropes
their necks I've assembled here 19
estimates and they spend quite a range
they what I've plotted here is the
percentage of skeletons showing signs of
violent trauma but they average out to
about 15% 15% of prehistoric remains
show some signs of violence let's
compare that 15 percent figure to those
of some modern state societies the
United States and Europe in the 20th
century with all of their Wars come out
at six tenths of one percent if you try
to bump up the estimate to the highest
credible value by throwing in all the
indirect deaths from starvation and
disease in the wake of a war all of the
genocides all the man-made famines you
can bump the figure up to about 3% and
if you look at the world in the 21st
century the graph is invisible at less
than a pixel high because it's less than
three one hundredths of 1% the second
source of evidence on rates of violence
in non-state societies comes from
ethnographic vital statistics the wave
of state settlement that swept over the
globe starting around 5000 years ago
left a few pockets of the earth still in
Anarchy namely a hunter-gatherer under
horticultural and other tribal societies
and ethnographers who have lived with
them for extended periods of time have
tallied up the rates of death from
various causes including warfare I found
27 estimates in the anthropological
literature and once again they spend
quite a range I've plotted them here as
war deaths per hundred thousand people
per year but the average is 524 for a
hundred thousand per year that is every
year one half of one percent of the
population dies in warfare let's compare
that 524 figure to those of some modern
states and I'll stack the deck against
modernity by picking some of the most
violent states in their most violent
periods such as Germany in the 20th
century with two world wars
and their rate is 144 Russia in the 20th
century two world wars and a civil war
135 Japan in the 20th century a world
war that ended in two nuclear explosions
with a rate of 27 United States in the
20th century with two world wars and
half a dozen other Foreign Wars with a
rate of 5.7 the world in the 20th
century again a seeking the maximum
estimate by summing the deaths direct
and indirect from war also the deaths
from genocide and man-made famines the
rate is about 60 and the world in the
21st century has a rate whose bar is
less than a pixel high at three tenths
of a more death per 100,000 per year so
not to put too fine a point on it but
when it comes to life in a state of
nature Hobbes was right Rousseau was
wrong the immediate cause was the rise
in expansion of states leading to the
various taxes that history students are
taught the Pax Romana pacts Islamic ax
taxes panic ax and so on as a state
exerts hegemony over a territory it will
tend to stamp out tribal raiding and
feuding not because the early kings and
emperors had a benevolent interest in
the welfare of their citizens but rather
because tribal tribal raiding and
feuding are a nuisance to the overlords
who would just as soon keep the people
alive to supply them with soldiers and
slaves and taxes so just as a farmer has
an interest in preventing his cattle
from killing each other not necessarily
because he cares for the cattle but
because it's just a dead loss to him so
the early kings and emperors had an
interest in pacifying the territories
that they controlled the second decline
of violence can be appreciated by
pondering this woodcut showing a day in
life in the Middle Ages
and the process that brought these rates
of violence down has been called the
civilizing process it turns out that
homicide statistics go back in many
parts of Europe 800 years and historical
criminologists have plotted them over
time such as in this plot of homicide
rates in England from 1200 to the
present it's plotted on a logarithmic
scale from a tenth of a homicide per
hundred thousand per year to one to ten
to a hundred and it shows that there has
been a massive decline in the rate of
homicide so that a contemporary
Englishman is about 135th as likely to
be murdered as his medieval ancestor
this is true not just in England but in
every country for which records go back
here we see Italy the Netherlands
Germany and Switzerland and Scandinavia
here is the average of those five
regions and for the sake of comparison
I've also plotted the rate for the
non-state societies that 524 per hundred
thousand per year figure this gap is
what I've been calling the pacification
process this further decline the
civilizing process the immediate cause
was identified by a German sociologist
named Norbert Elias in his book called
the civilizing process in which he
suggested that in the transition from
the Middle Ages to modernity there was a
consolidation of central States and
kingdoms out of the patchwork of feudal
Berenice and principalities and duchies
with it criminal justice was
nationalized and the constant feuding
and warlord activity of medieval knights
gave way to the King's justice also
during this transition there was a
growing infrastructure of Commerce
financial instruments such as money and
contracts that could be recognized
within the borders of the newly
consolidated States and technological
improvements such as better roads and
carts and instruments of time keeping
that lubricated commerce and exchange as
a result zero-sum plunder began began to
give way to positive some
a point that I'll return to toward the
end of the lecture this evening
the third historical transition can be
appreciated by recalling some of the
ways that the early kingdoms kept law
and order within their territories
brutal punishments such as breaking on
the wheel burning at the stake clawing
sawing-in-half and impairment but in a
process that's been called the
humanitarian revolution these forms of
sadistic gruesome punishment were
abolished this timeline shows the number
of major countries with torture as a
form of criminal punishment showing that
there was a precipitous decline in the
second half of the 18th century
including the prohibition of cruel and
unusual punishment in the 8th amendment
to the American Constitution which took
place right in the middle of this
process also abolished during the
humanitarian Revolution was the
profligate use of the death penalty for
non-lethal crimes in eighteenth-century
England there were 222 capital offenses
on the law books including poaching
counterfeiting robbing a rabbit warren
being in the company of gypsies and
strong evidence of malice in a child 47
to 14 years of age by 1861 the number of
capital crimes had been reduced to 4
likewise in the United States in the
17th and 18th centuries the death
penalty was prescribed and frequently
used for theft sodomy besty ality
adultery witchcraft concealing birth
slave revolt and counterfeiting indeed
this graph which runs from colonial
times to the present shows that the
percentage that several hundred years
ago a majority of executions were for
crimes other than murder
today the only crime other than murder
punished by death is conspiracy to
commit murder the death penalty itself
of course has been abolished in every
major democracy except the United States
here we have a timeline from 1775 to the
present showing the number of European
countries that have capital punishment
on the their law books
the most of the decline happened in the
20th century particularly the second
half of the 20th century but more
interesting is the blue timeline which
shows the number of European countries
that actually carry out executions which
show the decline that began far earlier
and on average fifty years elapsed
between the last time a execution was
actually carried out in a European
country and the time that the law makers
caught up with the practices and struck
the death penalty from their law books
now as I mentioned the United States as
with I have it must be said many of the
trends that I mentioned is in the lags
behind other Western democracies but
even in the United States for all its
notoriety the death penalty is a shadow
of its former self this graph from 1625
to the present shows the number of
executions per capita number per hundred
thousand people per year and as you can
see by historical standards even in
Texas they execute a tiny fraction of
the number of people that used to be
routinely executed in the past today in
the United States there about 40
executions
per year in a country that has more than
16,000 homicides per year and over the
course of the two years in which I wrote
better angels of our nature I had to
amend it three times because three more
states abolished capital punishment
between the time I began the book and
the time I sent it to the publisher and
that is a trend that is bound to
continue also abolished during the
humanitarian Revolution were witch hunts
religious persecution like burning
heretics dueling blood sports debtors
prisons and most famously of all slavery
slavery used to be legal everywhere on
the planet the Bible had no problem with
it
democratic Athens no problem at all then
starting in the 18th century country
after country began to abolish slavery a
process that culminated in 1980 with the
abolition of slavery and more attained
yeah with the result that for the last
three decades we've been living in an
unprecedented period in history in which
slavery is not legal anywhere on the
planet what were the immediate causes of
the humanitarian revolution a plausible
answer might be affluence perhaps as
people's lives get longer and more
comfortable they place a higher value on
their own life and by extension life in
general including the lives of others
unfortunately the timing doesn't seem to
work this graph which shows per capita
income in England from 1220 to the
present shows that the lion's share of
the improvement took place in the 19th
century with the Industrial Revolution
the affluence barely budged during the
18th century when these reforms were
launched a more empirically justifiable
answer would be the rise of printing and
literacy this graph shows that prior to
the 18th century there was a 25 fold
increase in the efficiency of book
production that those gains were put
into practice so that in the 18th
century there was an exponential
increase in the number of books
published per year a kind of early
version of Moore's law and it was during
the 18th century that for the first time
a majority of Englishmen could read them
that's when literacy first broke the 50%
mark and stayed there
why should literacy matter well there's
another name for this revolution we call
it the Enlightenment because knowledge
began to replace superstition and
ignorance and if you have a literate and
better and better informed population
that gets disabused of notions such as
that Jews poison wells heretics go to
hell witches cause crop failures
children are possessed by the devil
which has to be beaten out of them
Africans are brutish and fit for and
only for enslavement then the
institutions are bound to change as a
result as Voltaire said during this era
those who can make you believe
absurdities can make you commit a try
cities also literacy is a technology of
cosmopolitanism the mixing of people and
ideas and it's not implausible that as
people begin to consume more fiction and
history and journalism they start to
inhabit other people's minds try to
imagine what the lives of others are
like and conceivably this could expand
their circle of empathy and decrease
their taste for cruelty another idea
that I'll return to toward the end of
the talk
the fourth decline of violence has been
called the long peace and it speaks to
the frequently made assertion that the
20th century was the most violent in
history however people who make that
claim never cite numbers from any
century other than the 20th this is a
trend based on one data point and there
are many reasons to doubt it for one
thing the so-called peaceful 19th
century was not so peaceful if you look
at the entire world and the entire
century the 19th century saw in Europe
the Napoleonic Wars one of the most
destructive wars in European history of
4 million deaths the most destructive
civil war in history which few people
have even heard of the Taiping rebellion
in China with 20 million deaths the most
destructive war in American history the
Civil War 650,000 in southern Africa the
conquests of Shaka Zulu killed 1 to 2
million people in South America the most
proportionally destructive interstate
war of all times was the war of the
Triple Alliance which killed perhaps 60
percent of the population of Paraguay
then there were African slave raiding
Wars and imperial wars in Africa Asia
and the South Pacific whose death tolls
we can't even begin to estimate also
though it's certainly true that the
Second World War was the deadliest
single event in human history in terms
of the absolute number of people who are
killed it is not as clear that it is the
deadliest event in terms of the
proportion of the population that was
affected because the 20th century after
all had more people than earlier
centuries here I've taken a list of the
hundred worst things that people have
ever done to each other from a man who
calls himself an atrocity latest math
Matthew white and I've plotted them over
2500 years of human history from 500 BCE
to the present scaled by the population
of the world at the time
as you can see history's worst
atrocities were pretty evenly
distributed over 2,500 years of human
history
there is to be sure oh and by the way
world war two comes in at ninth place
world war one doesn't even make the top
ten there is to be sure a funneling down
of the data cloud as you get closer to
the present but presumably this doesn't
mean that in ancient times they only
committed really big atrocities and more
recently we've also been committing
medium-sized and small atrocities but
far more likely it's a reflection of the
historical record the farther back you
go the less likely it was that a smaller
atrocity was recorded by anyone we can
for the last 500 years zoom in because
the invention of the printing press and
and spread of literacy means that our
historical records are better and look
at trends in great power war these are
the wars that affect the 5 to 10 biggest
countries or empires of the day the
800-pound gorillas whose wars because of
the statistical distribution of war I
count for a majority of deaths in all
wars combined
and whose wars were momentous enough
that they were unlikely to have been
missed by any of the chroniclers of the
day this is a data set that comes from
Jack levy the first graph all of these
spend a half a millennium showed the
proportion of years that the great
powers fought each other and what it
shows us that several hundred years ago
the figures were often a hundred percent
that is the great powers were fighting
each other in a hundred percent of years
that's kind of what great powers did
they fought other great powers but more
recently the
figure has fallen to zero this graph
shows the duration of wars involving a
great power which also has been in
decline history used to have things like
the 30 Years War the eighty years war
the Hundred Years War the 20th century
had the Six Day War here we have the
frequency of wars with a great power on
at least one side and that too has been
in decline over the last 500 years there
was however one trend that went in the
opposite direction for most of this
period which is once a great power
started a war how many people wasn't
able to kill per country per year and
because of developments in military
technology and organization that figure
actually increased for most of this
period Wars became more deadly once they
began but even that figure did a u-turn
after the Second World War so we're now
living in an era in which the frequency
of wars the duration of wars and the
concentration of deadliness of wars are
all simultaneously in decline if you
multiply those figures out to tally the
total number of deaths from all great
power wars combined the trends do a lot
of canceling and zigzagging for most of
the time but the lowest point in 500
years corresponds to the most recent
quarter century for the last hundred
years we can zoom in still in finer
detail and plot the rate of death from
all wars from the 20th century in the
first decade of the 21st and what the
graph shows us that there were two
unmistakable huh spikes of bloodletting
centered on the two world wars but
contrary to predictions that this would
just begin a sequence of more and more
destructive wars the Second World War
turned out to be something more of a
last-gasp than a harbinger of things to
come and since then the rate of wars has
been deaths and warm sorry has been in
decline this is the period that
historians call the long piece the fact
that since 1946 there's been
historically unprecedented decline in
interstate Wars
that is wars with a government on each
side in fact the most striking statistic
of the long piece is zero refers to the
number of wars between the two greatest
powers of them all the US and the Soviet
Union contrary to all expert predictions
World War three never happened no
nuclear weapon has been used since
Nagasaki again every expert predicted
that a nuclear war was inevitable it
never happened
there'd been no wars between any two
great powers since the end of the Korean
War in 1953 no wars between Western
European countries and sometimes people
have to be reminded that this is an
interesting development I it would be
easy to think well of course there art
who would ever expect say France and
Germany to go to war but this intuition
is itself historically surprising prior
to 1945 there were two new Wars a year
for 600 years in Western Europe alone as
after 1945 that fell to zero and there
been no wars between developed countries
since 1945 the 40 richest countries in
the world have not come to blows again
this almost sounds obvious we think of
war as something that happens in those
poor backward parts of the southern
hemisphere but this it was not always
like this it used to be the richest most
advanced countries that were constantly
at each other's throats and because
these were big rich countries that could
afford big destructive armies the wars
that they didn't get embroiled in could
cause a lot of damage well what about
the rest of the world in a process that
I call the new piece the long piece
appears to be spreading to the rest of
the world now I mentioned that since
1946 there have been fewer interstate
Wars there have however been more civil
wars as newly independent states with
inept governments defended themselves
against insurgent movements both sides
often armed financed and egged on by the
cold war superpowers but let me show you
this trend quantitatively in a
stacked layer graph where the thickness
of each layer that I'm going to show you
corresponds to the number of wars in
each of four categories where a war for
the point of this graph is an armed
conflict that kills as few as 25 people
in a year first we have the number of
colonial wars since 1946 and that
abruptly ended in the 1970s as the last
European Empire gave up the last of its
colonies here we have the number of
interstate Wars very few as I mentioned
and trickling down to hardly any however
here we have the number of pure civil
wars and the number of internationalized
civil wars where some external power
buts in to help the government defend
itself and both of those showed an
increase through the early 90s but with
the end of the Cold War even the number
of civil wars started to decline and the
total number of wars therefore which is
represented by the height of the entire
stack the crucial question though is
which Wars kill more people the
declining number of Interstate Wars or
the increasing number of civil wars and
the answer is - that is pretty clear
here we have the deadliness of
Interstate Wars and those have been that
is the number of people killed per
conflict per year and those have been in
precipitous decline the increase in the
deadliness of internationalised and pure
civil wars doesn't come close to making
up for the decline in deaths from the
interstate Wars if you now once again
multiply these two figures together
number of Wars number of people killed
per war you get the following stacked
layer graph here we have the number the
rate of death from colonial wars which
tapered off to 0 the rate of death from
interstate Wars which shows a bumpy but
unmistakable decline with spikes
corresponding to the Korean War the
Vietnam War and the iran-iraq war and
here we have the rate of death from pure
civil wars and internationally
civil wars the entire stack has shows a
decline and here we are in the first
decade of the 20th century with a thin
laminate of layers showing a
historically unprecedented low rate of
death for a war of all kinds altogether
what were the immediate causes of the
long peace and the new peace
well three hypotheses were thrown out
200 years ago by Immanuel Kant in his
essay perpetual peace in which he argued
that democracy trade and an
international community should work to
disincentivize leaders from starting
destructive wars more recently the
political scientist Bruce russet and
John O'Neill have tested kansai pothinus
with a large data set of militarized
disputes and they found that Kant got it
right three out of three times all of
these have increased in the second half
of the 20th century and all of them are
statistical predictors of peace holding
all other factors constant here for
example you see the number of
democracies in the world which has
increased and the number of autocracies
which has decreased we're living in a
time where there are more democracies
than autocracies here we see
international trade which skyrocketed
starting after the Second World War and
here we have the membership in
intergovernmental organizations such as
the United Nations whose Charter was
signed I believe here in this very
building and which however it culminated
a trend that began much earlier but one
that accelerated after the end of the
Second World War there are lots and lots
of intergovernmental organizations
forming a virtual international
community that nations increasingly
belong to finally we have the rights
revolutions the targeting of violence on
smaller scales directed against
vulnerable sectors of the population
such as racial minorities women children
homosexuals and animals the civil rights
revolution put an end to the practice of
lynching at the end of the 19th century
more than 150 African Americans were
lynched in the United States every year
that fell precipitously and reached zero
by the 1950s hate crime murders of
blacks have only been recorded since the
1990s and they were never very plentiful
to begin with but they have decreased to
one a year non-lethal hate crimes
against blacks such as intimidation and
assault have been in decline and the
kind of racist attitudes that set the
stage for violence against blacks have
also been in decline here we have the
results of two public opinion polls from
the 1940s to the present asking whether
white Americans whether black and white
students should go to separate schools
and whether they would move out if a
black family moved in next door
both of them have declined from the
majority of the population to the single
digits
they're now considered to be in the
range of crank opinion and the questions
aren't even included on in the
questionnaires anymore this is a
worldwide phenomenon this graph shows
the number of countries that
discriminate against ethnic minorities
with a part hate or Jim Crow laws the
blue line shows the number of countries
that bend over backwards with remedial
or affirmative action policies to try to
bring up the status of their formerly
discriminated against minorities now we
have more countries with affirmative
action policies than we have countries
with discriminatory policies the women's
rights revolution has seen an 80%
decrease in the rate of rape since
statistics were first kept a similarly
dramatic decline in rates of domestic
violence a dramatic decline in the most
extreme form of domestic violence of all
namely ixora side the killing of
girlfriends and wives and mur it aside
the killing of boyfriends and husbands
and the graph shows somewhat
surprisingly that there's been an even
steeper decline in the rate of killing
of male partners
than female partners the women's rights
movement has been very very good for
husbands the children's rights
revolution has seen a steady decline in
the number of American states that
permit corporal punishment in schools
like paddling and strapping every public
opinion poll in the West has shown a
decline in the approval and practice of
spanking children rates of child abuse
have gone down since they were first
measured both physical abuse and sexual
abuse as have rates of violence in
school yards and playgrounds such as
fights and non-fatal crimes the gay
rights revolution has seen an increase
in the number of states that have
decriminalized homosexuality both nation
states worldwide and American States
which now stands at 50 out of 50
following a Supreme Court decision
anti-gay attitudes have been in steady
decline such as whether homosexuality is
considered morally wrong whether it
should be made illegal or whether gay
people should be denied equal
opportunity and the anti-gay hate crime
of intimidation has been in decline
since records were first kept finally
the animal rights movement has seen a
decline in hunting an increase in
vegetarianism both in the UK and the US
and a sharp decline in the number of
motion pictures in which animals were
harmed well this all this brings up the
question why has violence declined on so
many scales of time and magnitude one
possibility is that human nature has
changed and that somehow people have had
their inclinations toward violence
literally bred out of them well I
consider this possibility extremely
unlikely for one thing we still see
violence in our unsocialized children a
large percentage of two-year-olds kick
bite and hit and play fighting among
boys is one of the most robust human
universals we continue to get tremendous
enjoyment out of witnessing simulated
and vicarious violence
as in murder mysteries Greek tragedies
Shakespearean dramas video games hockey
and movies starring a certain excavate
and then there are homicidal fantasies
a number of social psychologists have
asked people the following question
have you ever fantasized about killing
someone you don't like well it turns out
that about 15% of women and a third of
men frequently fantasize about killing
people about 60% of women and 75% of men
at least occasionally fantasize about
killing people what does this say about
human nature it tells us that 25% of men
are liars a more likely possibility is
that human nature is extraordinarily
complex and has always comprised
inclinations toward violence and
inclinations that counteract them what
Abraham Lincoln called me called the
better angels of our nature and that
historical circumstances have
increasingly favored our peaceable
inclinations what are the motives for
violence that I think are always with us
one of them is the incentive to raw
exploitation the elimination of a person
that happens to be an obstacle on the
path to something that you want
resulting in rape plunder conquest and
the elimination of rivals there's
dominance the urge among individuals to
climb the pecking order and become alpha
male and the corresponding urge among
groups for ethnic racial national or
religious supremacy
there's revenge or moralistic violence
the conviction that not only is violence
justifiable but it is obligatory to
punish some prior harm or sin resulting
in vendetta's rough justice and cruel
punishments and then there are I do geez
that license violence such as militant
religions nationalism Nazism and
communism which justify violence by a
kind of pernicious
cost-benefit analysis premise on the
hope of a utopia a world that will be
infinitely good forever if the ends are
infinitely good then the means can be as
violent as you want and you're always
ahead of the game you're always on the
positive side of the ledger also let's
say that you announce your dream of a
world that would be infinitely good
forever and there are some people who
just don't get with the program
they stand in your way they are the only
thing that is blocking the world that
will be infinitely good forever
well how evil are they you do the math
they are deserving of arbitrarily severe
punishment and that's why paradoxically
the worst atrocities in human history
were motivated by idealistic moralistic
movements well what do we have on the
other side to counteract these motives
for violence what are the better angels
of our nature their self control
circuitry concentrated in the frontal
lobe of the brain that can anticipate
the consequences of behavior and inhibit
our violent impulses there's empathy the
ability to feel others pain there's the
moral sense a set of norms and taboos
that regulate behavior and finally
there's Reason cognitive processes that
allow us to engage in objective detached
analysis the key question now being
which historical developments bring out
our better angels and stay our hands
before they can commit acts of bloodshed
one possibility is that hops got it
right when he called for a Leviathan a
state and judicial system with a
monopoly on the legitimate use of
violence a state can reduce violence by
eliminating the incentives for
exploitative attack by penalizing
aggression and there by canceling out
any anticipated game that can have
knock-on effects by in turn reducing the
need for preemptive strikes let's do it
to them before they do it to us for
parents maintaining a belligerent stance
to prove one's mettle and of course
vengeance after the fact in particular
by outsourcing our security and revenge
to a disinterested third party we can
circumvent self-serving biases that
social psychologists have shown that
people are prone to everyone always
thinks that the other guys attacks are
naked unprovoked aggression out of the
blue whereas their own attacks are
justified retaliation after the fact
when you have one side counting an even
number of attacks and believing that the
scores have been settled the other
counting an odd number of attacks and
believing that there's still justice to
be done you can have endless cycles of
revenge vendetta and blood feud a spiral
that can be nipped in the bud when it's
some disinterested third party that is
judging and meeting out justice some
historical evidence for the effects of
the Leviathan come from the pacifying
and civilizing effects of states that I
mentioned earlier in the talk and the
fact that we can watch this movie in
Reverse when government retreats leading
behind zones of Anarchy which are almost
inevitably violent the American Wild
West where you all remember the cliche
of the cowboy movies the nearest sheriff
is 120 miles away so you've got to
defend yourself with your six-shooter
failed states collapsed empires and
mafias and street gangs who deal in
contraband and therefore have to do
business in a zone of anarchy if you're
a crack dealer and you think you've been
cheated in a deal it's not like you can
press a lawsuit if you feel threatened
you can't dial nine-one-one because the
activity you're engaged in is illegally
in the first place and this is why
contraband economies which necessarily
live in pockets of Anarchy often breed
high rates of violence a second
historical mechanism is the idea of
gentle Commerce the idea that plunder is
a zero-sum game
the or negative sum the gain to the
victor is canceled out by the loss to
the victim
whereas trade is a positive sum game one
in which everybody can win and as
improving technology allows the trade of
goods and ideas over longer distances
among larger groups of people and at
lower cost more and more of the rest of
the world becomes more valuable alive
than dead and because it becomes more it
becomes cheaper to buy stuff than to
steal it an obvious example is that
despite all of the talk about the
economic rivalry between the United
States and China it is extraordinarily
unlit unlikely that they will fight a
war among other things they make all our
stuff and we owe them too much money
some historical evidence comes from a
statistical study showing that countries
with open economies and a greater
reliance on international trade are less
likely to get embroiled in wars or Riven
by fewer civil wars and hosts fewer
genocides a third mechanism has been
called the expanding circle the term was
originated by Peter singer but the
concept goes back to Charles Darwin that
evolution gave us the capacity for
empathy but unfortunately by default we
applied only to a narrow circle of blood
relatives close allies and cute little
warm fuzzy animals but over the course
of history one can see the circle of
empathy expanding from the family to the
village the clan the tribe the nation
other races both sexes children and
perhaps eventually other species well
this just begs the question of what
expand in the circle and the
technologies of cosmopolitanism that I
alluded to earlier are a plausible
candidate the availability of history
literature and journalism and a number
of experiments have shown that if you
get someone to read or hear the words of
another person they will not only become
more
and Pathak toward that person but to the
entire category of people that that
individual represents some historical
evidence comes from the fact that
humanitarian reforms are often preceded
by new technologies for spreading ideas
the 18th century the humanitarian
Revolution was preceded by the Republic
of Letters the massive expansion of
literacy and printed discourse the 20th
century's long peace and rights
revolution were preceded by the
electronic Global Village and in the
20th century though it's a bit too soon
to tell if the color revolutions and
Arab Spring have happy endings they will
certainly be attributed to the rise of
the internet and social media finally
there's the escalator of reason the
possibility that the expansion of
literacy education and public discourse
have encouraged people to think more
abstractly and more universally they
rise above their parochial vantage point
which makes it harder to privilege their
own interests over others people step
back and recognize the futility of
cycles of violence and increasingly see
violence as a problem to be solved
rather than as a contest to be won some
historical evidence comes from the fact
that abstract reasoning abilities as
measured by IQ tests increased over the
course of the 20th century another
strange but true secular trend the so
called Flynn effect by which IQ scores
throughout the 20th century increased by
about 3 IQ points per decade other
studies have shown that people in
societies with higher levels of
education and measured intelligence
commit fewer violent crimes holding all
else constant cooperate more in
experimental games have more classically
liberal attitudes such as opposition to
racism homophobia and xenophobia and are
more receptive to democracy in their
countries 10 years down the line
the final question that all addresses if
these four historical forces are all
making us less violent why do they all
seem to be pushing in the same direction
I think it's because violence is what
game theorists call a social dilemma
it's always tempting to an aggressor to
exploit a victim but of course it is far
more damaging to the victim since in the
long run
victims can become exploiters and vice
versa all parties would be better off if
everyone could somehow agree to renounce
violence the dilemma is how do you get
the other guy to refrain from violence
at the same time as you do since if you
beat your swords into plowshares but the
other guy keeps his as swords you could
find yourself at the wrong end of an
invading army it's not implausible to
think that over the course of history
human experience and human ingenuity
have gradually worked away on this
problem and chipped away at it just like
we've dealt with other scourge 'as of
the human condition like pestilence and
hunger and the common denominator among
the four historical forces that I
mentioned is that all of them increase
the material emotional or cognitive
incentives of all parties to avoid
violence simultaneously regardless of
what the best explanation of the decline
of violence turns out to be I think it
has implications that are profound among
other things it calls for a
reorientation of our efforts towards
violence reduction from a moralistic
mindset to an empirical mindset that is
instead of just lamenting why is there
war perhaps we should ask why is there
peace not just what are we doing wrong
but what have we been doing right
because we have been doing something
right
and it seems to me to be quite important
to figure out what exactly it is also
the decline of violence calls for a
reassessment of modernity of the
centuries-long
developments that have eroded the
influence of family tribe tradition and
religion giving way to individualism
cosmopolitanism reason and science now
everyone acknowledges that modernity has
brought us numerous
ift's longer and healthier lives less
ignorant sin superstition richer
experiences but there's always been a
current of nostalgia and romanticism
that has questioned the price is it
worth it if we have to live in the
shadow of terrorism genocide world wars
and nuclear weapons but if despite
impressions the long-term trend though
halting and incomplete is that violence
of all kinds is decreasing
I believe that calls for a
rehabilitation of the ideals of
modernity and progress and it's a cause
for gratitude for the institutions of
civilization and enlightenment that have
made it possible thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the paperback that there's lots
of signed copies of Thank You Bobby and
so it's a year later I guess since that
came out what's been going on in the
world in relation to this book since
then he had reviews pro and con probably
there must have been so many historians
who said what's the social psych i'll
psychiatrists doing writing history yes
historians are that is certainly true
and and there are some historians for
whom I am something of a carpetbagger
coming into their you know invading
their territory with all these numbers
and for me a social scientists this is
just the kind of data that I always deal
with that multiple regressions and
statistical distributions and just the
for me the obvious way to evaluate
hypothesis it seems to me that anytime
you use a word like increase or decrease
or better or worse you're making a
quantitative claim you're saying there
are two points in time and there's a
quantity and at one point it was higher
than it is at a later point and or vice
versa and so that whole class of
historical hypotheses ought to be
amenable to quantitative examination
then granted we don't have ideal data
stretching back 2500 years the farther
back you go the worse the data become
but there are orders of magnitude and
they themselves tell a story so our who
are the historians who are slapping
their forehead and saying oh my god he's
right and rethink what we do now well I
find that actually an awful lot of his
story and say their attitude is not so
much he's wrong or oh my goodness look
what he's shown it's that well we kind
of knew this but it's kind of uncouth to
say it or to made much of a deal about
it partly because it seemed for various
professional and moralistic reasons well
is it minimizing the tragedies of the
20th century
is it saying that Western civilization
has been doing something right we can't
admit that so I find that it's actually
I haven't gotten a lot of that don't
have gotten any historians who actually
said no the trends going in the opposite
direction
the only exception has been almost a
philosophical argument that as long as
we have the capacity to kill more people
more efficiently namely nuclear weapons
you can't say we're less violent if we
have the capability to do it let speak
to Paul Hawkens question he says despite
the decline in violence as that had any
impact upon the amount of fear that
people experienced with respect to
terrorism potential violence and so on
no it's a great question then the answer
is probably not
and in fact I just saw the results of an
opinion poll that shows that in the 21st
century compared to the Cold War people
are more worried about death and
destruction than they were when the US
and Soviet Union were aiming ICBMs at
each other
and this is a I think a textbook case in
the psychology of fear as opposed to the
assessment of risk that so what is a
social psychologist what do you make it
at is there this sounds like one of
those human nature things or is you know
that there's a there's got to always be
so much fear and we'll use anything to
keep it going well for terrorism itself
is a is itself a technology of fear you
can see that in the word that's when you
know the terror and terrorism means it's
how do you manufacture the greatest
amount of fear per unit damage and
terrorism actually aside from the purely
hypothetical possibility of nuclear
terrorism but actual terrorism kills
a very small number of people even the
worst terrorist event in history 9/11
which killed about 2,700 people that's
2,700 tragedies and crimes but compared
to the Wars of years past compared to
homicides compared to you know traffic
accidents it's really not a major risk
factor for life and limb and of course
combined with the weather the terrorist
groups want to achieve namely
manufacturing fear there was the Bush
administration that did its best to
amplify the fear within the duct tape
and the the orange warnings Jenica
largest panic
I think was more panic than cynicism
there may have been some cynicism -
Marshall Crouch says what about the
threats of mass destruction and we hear
about weapons of mass destruction over
and over again yet atomic bomb hydrogen
bomb bioterror such well let's see the
certainly the risk of a nuclear war is
far smaller than it was during the Cold
War there has been I think it's not a
coincidence that no nuclear weapon has
been used since Nagasaki
they basically other than deterring
existential threats
they really have played very little role
in war that's why many countries without
nuclear weapons have defied countries
with them knowing that the destruction
of a nuclear weapon is so
disproportionate to any military
achievement that that they are more of a
bluff than an actual threat Argentina
invading the Falklands in 1981 is a
perfect example Britain had nukes
Argentina didn't but Argentina and the
generals knew that Britain wasn't going
to leave Buenos Aires a radioactive
crater that and there are many other
examples so given that the risk of
interstate war is
getting less and less given that even in
the interstate wars that have occurred
not even a tactical battlefield nuclear
weapon has been used I think it's safe
to say that the risk is extremely low
now for nuclear terrorism the there
probably was a window of vulnerability
where unguarded nukes from you know
poorly guarded sites in the former
Soviet Union were vulnerable but even
the my understanding of the nuclear
security consensus is that that loophole
that window has been closed there is
still a nonzero risk of pilfering of
nuclear material that could result in
the so-called you know garage nuke even
that the people who actually try to
estimate the probability I think are
pretty close agreement that it's very
small not that we should be complacent
about it not there shouldn't be
intelligence operations that do their
darndest but is it likely I don't think
it's likely I think I'm gonna sue the
idea of this sort of diet of fear in the
way that Hawken brought up which is and
makes me wonder if people were fearful
all the time back in the violent Middle
Ages or hundred gatherer periods that
you talked about as you point out we now
like to we use violence as entertainment
a lot and Game of Thrones is doing very
well
taken to is in the theaters right now
because there's a wonderfully violent
total revenge story basically and then
we have this kind of interesting just
placed large-scale figure of it must be
a very dangerous world because
technology is moving so rapidly and
therefore unpredictably and there bill
joy must be right that that the end of
the super empowered individual who's
sufficiently crazy can do enormous
possibly total harm are we doing fear
instead of violence yeah well I think I
think we are doing a lot of fear for one
thing and not just fear but also fear
and concern that is the impression that
there's a lot of violence which is
stoked by the availability of technology
that can report violence more
efficiently wherever it occurs nowadays
anyone with a cell phone and I don't
know what the figures are for cell phone
penetration globally but there probably
knows how many cell phones out there
person what percentage of the world's
population is cell phone enabled more
than 50% right 5.7 billion people are
five billion cell phones everyone with
you or a large percentage of which can
beam color video footage globally
instantly and so the violence the
dezerter gets reported compares a world
war one where the British government
censored all war photography until well
after the war was over those horrific
battlefield scenes strewn with corpses
Effects of poison gas were only released
after the war that is not possible today
and the the benevolent result is that
people are more horrified by violence
and I think that the availability of
media that report violence was one of
the factors that drove it down on the
other hand it also leads to the
misimpression and then the world is more
violent than ever because of what
cognitive psychologists have shown
drives impressions of risk namely
memorable anecdotes if you can imagine a
quarry plane crash you think that plane
travel is dangerous the far more
plentiful deaths in car accidents don't
get reported on the evening news and so
you don't have any the same impression
as to how calm and they are so photos
all 7 billion people read your book and
you retired but
again I'm working on this sort of budget
of fear if people have the confidence in
your numbers and in the reality of the
president that violence cruelty and
injustice actually is going down has
further down to go obviously but we've
got a record of a success that we can
build on
well the society be like that was less
beautiful yeah I am you know I tend to
think that that contrary to they concern
that if you publicize the progress that
we made people will get complacent
I will desensitize people I think it's
the other way around that that there's a
danger of compassion fatigue of
resignation
human nature means we'll always be at
each other's throats Africa as a
hellhole what's the point of even trying
to stop the violence they'll always kill
each other if you when you see the
graphs and you see it going down you
realize well no actually for whatever
reason we really more and more of the
world can be made more peaceful
something we're doing something right I
tend to think that it empowers people it
certainly changed my own attitude when
going over these that what do you mean
from what the what well I I think I was
more likely to say there's just nothing
you know nothing works UN peacekeeping
doesn't work democracy doesn't work
because you can think of failures well
it didn't stop the United Nations didn't
stop the genocide in Rwanda or in
Sarajevo
we try to make it rock and democracy and
look what happened there and it is true
that there since all of these trends are
statistical there are counter examples
the counter examples are far more
newsworthy than the success stories you
never see a guy in front of a camera
with a microphone saying Here I am in
Managua and for 23 the 23rd year in a
row there is no civil war or I'm at the
you know I'm at the foot of the bed of
you know Jaime Garfinkel and he's dying
a cancer in his 87th year boring whereas
if the same guy got blown to bits you
can bet that it would lead the news and
so the because all of these trends are
statistical they haven't brought
violence down to zero there are always
enough examples to fill the news since
our cognitive assessment of risk is
driven by anecdotes and examples we're
going to be under the impression that
nothing works even if the statistics
massively show an effect of some if you
want statistical literacy absolutely
become the norm absolutely and I'll give
you one example because this is one
again that people can't appreciate if
they just think of the goriest incidence
and that is United Nations and other
peacekeeping forces guys are the blue
helmets to get themselves in between
warring parties or that help pacify
country after a ceasefire prevent
recidivism I do they work the answer
from the statistical studies is
absolutely they work massively they it
is a country is much less likely to fall
back in civil war if they've got armed
peacekeepers and the better financed and
armed the peacekeeping force the more
effective they are so this calls for
boosting and here again the the setting
is appropriate 1945 right here signed
the UN Charter the United Nations does a
number of things badly but it does a
number of things well and one of them is
peacekeeping on average not 100% at the
time the headlines would never tell you
that only a statistical study would so
you've been analyzing sort of
human mental moral ethical behavior
change and some of you put in the
individual and some of it you put in
this larger entity that I guess social
psychologists look at that is something
like society how do those two relate
yeah we think this is one of the
frontiers of social science
how does individual psychology
interconnected in social networks result
in change in this strange entity we call
the vanity is the Internet now you've
one of your statements in there that
I'll use in my summary is that new
technologies of spreading ideas spread
peacefulness basically well so is that
gonna act my answer was more generic
than that because it's not just the
internet it's not and when I talk about
social networks I don't mean Facebook I
may understand everything going back to
Z and and even before literacy language
face-to-face communication I mean the
general social scientists have often
talked about this thing called culture
and society but there's cultures in this
gas or miasma or entity that actually
exists separate from coordinated beliefs
and negotiated agreements among large
numbers of people and the question of
how changes in individual psychology
propagate mmm across social networks
including face-to-face interaction to
change this thing called culture I think
is one of the great frontiers of
research and social science so how do
norms for example propagate so quickly
even when they are not enforced by the
top from the top down by a Leviathan so
in our own lifetimes for example I had a
social gathering among educated people
no one would tell F neck jokes that
wasn't true when I was a child for
example there's no as far as I know
there's no law against it police aren't
gonna come in and arrest you but it
would just be horrifying now in a way
that wasn't true in
same when when that when we were
children or you know there many examples
you know letting your dog poop on the
sidewalk wasn't so long ago that that
that people did that and now it would be
close to unthinkable yeah everybody
doesn't make exceptions but it's the
exceptions that you know yeah it tells
you there's a rule and a liberal and
conservative attitudes which have been
moving inexorably in the liberal
direction with conservatives always you
know kicking and screaming in the
rearguard
but debates that used to be held are no
longer held they're no longer within the
realm of thinkable options racial
segregation is one there used to be
debates on it with you know two sides
that was decided it's a done deal
equal employment opportunities for women
access to facilities by the handicapped
gays in the military laws against the
criminalize homosexuality once they're
done you know they're done and how that
so there are certain reforms that are
done with a stroke of a pen but there
are other things that just become you
know unthinkable you just don't you
don't go there anymore okay I'd love to
know how that happens your so many
hasn't gone away there's two questions
out Janna Thompson asks how do you see
the role of religion in either the
increase or decrease of violence Richard
Lee asks what effects has the rise of
secularism and religious fundamentalism
had on trends and violence yeah well the
thing about religion is that it itself
is both effect and cause of a lot of
these developments so there's no easy
answer to whether religions make things
more or less peaceful because the very
forces that I think that have changed
attitudes and practices have changed
religions so we don't religion isn't
what it used to be the major thing of
Christianity I can just tell Judaism to
another well keep first heresy Judaism
to the verge Old Testament Bible very
tough right today I don't think we think
it's such a great idea to Massacre every
last Midianite every
child or Moabite or Jebusite or you know
his eyes and so on
no Christian sect today would advocate
burning heretics at the stake so the
religions themselves have done a lot of
damage just checking and so even though
certain at certain times in history
militant religions have like later
ideologies and resulted in huge numbers
of deaths that the European Wars of
Religion the Crusades are examples and
there is I think still a danger from the
militant versions of Islam as we see
they're likely to change over time is
Islam going through something now maybe
the Christianity went through 300 years
ago with the latest Lord I think it's
not implausible
I wouldn't predict it with you know with
the high high confidence but I think
it's certainly a a plausible scenario
how two religions and ideologies
intersect if at all because one of the
strong arguments in your book is the
ideologies are lethal and you make the
point that it ease that have a utopian
vision of where we can get to and the
infinite value of that then makes
plausible causing doing very evil things
in the near term because it'll pay off
in the future ideologies relate to
religions at all yes well I think
religions are based on on ideologies and
I think what we're seeing is a new
ideology you want to call it that I
think psychologically it functions like
an ideology but the difference being
that it can actually be rationally
justified that is the doctrine of
humanism or human rights the idea that
all moral legal and political systems
ought to maximize the flourishing and
minimizing the suffering of sentient
beings
now that sounds almost like you know to
us like pabulum like well yeah these are
numberless I've outer Savin that's in
the religion every way sentient beings
are numberless I vow to save them as a
religion
saying from Buddhism oh okay well
they're ahead of its time then but it's
actually surprising how radical and new
this idea is and the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights is only
passed in 1948 and the the advocates of
it had to pull teeth and and and twist
arms to get countries to sign it the
idea that every one every individual
human has a right to life and liberty
and flourishing because the easier idea
is but is the the one that comes
naturally to us and includes intuitions
like tribalism the glory of the ethnic
group the tribe the clan the nation the
religion is has primacy and individual
people are just like cells in a body
like ants in a colony or bees in a hive
and are expendable
it's the hive itself that's valuable the
idea that purity sanctity are bigger
than any one of us and that it's
permissible to kill in order to preserve
the purity or sanctity of the group all
of these intuitions which Jonathan Hite
has identified I think height is right
that they do tend to define our moral
intuitions and here's why I disagree
with height I think it's a purging of a
lot of these probably biological sources
of moral intuitions down to the austere
narrow doctrine of human rights as our
acceptable moral ideology that is the
cause of the decline of violence in the
realm of ideas and the great ideological
change is that the doctrine of human
rights as opposed to communism and
nationalism and fascism and nazism and
militant religions doesn't lead to more
humane practices so I've been bugging
you to do a book in the history of
ideologies you think there's an
interesting history to be told they're
not by you by somebody I think there is
an interesting history and I think
there's an interesting I don't know if
you want to call it
connection science or social network
science the kind of thing that there's
Nicholas Christakis and James Fowler and
Duncan Watts and and Michael Macy do
that is how do norms proliferate and
consolidate themselves in a society
given that the society is in one way of
looking at it it's the sum of the
individual human minds that make it up
hit another way of looking at it there
are norms that seem to have a life of
their own by virtue of being coordinated
in many many minds simultaneously
sometimes for good sometimes for for ill
include toxic beliefs and ideologies
that we know from history can spread
extraordinary popular delusions and the
madness of crowds witch hunts for
example people were convinced early said
they were convinced that that witches
could turn men into dogs and cause ships
to sink and crop failures things that
your own eyes tell you can't be true but
that society-wide
that belief can become entrenched I
think it's a very exciting and important
topic how these society-wide effects can
grow out of the transfer of beliefs
among individuals one of the things you
refer to is cosmopolitanism and there's
a book by that name by Kwame Apia
ethical philosopher and urbanization is
one of the things to basically you know
skyrocketing right now will probably
level off there were 80 percent urban as
cosmopolitan that suggests that when
were 80 percent urban will be you know
seriously that kind of less violent and
less hurtful
lest unjust because we well explained
how the what is cosmopolitan ethics yeah
well it's the in obvious conception it's
partly the the fact that individuals can
have multiple identities so thank you by
day leather by night yes yes for example
yeah or the question that was pretty
common a hundred years ago guys and
shoes to go around a cowboy boot another
example yes you know 100 years ago that
great progressive President Woodrow
Wilson said that any referral to you
know Italian Americans and polish
Americans said that any person with a
hyphen in his identity is like a - is
like a dagger
aimed at the heart of the Republic now
that is it's you don't know whether it's
revolting or quaint or puzzling but we
can't have that belief anymore
it just seems like what do you mean you
can't have an italian-american I'm again
you have to choose whether you're
Italian you know American you can't be
both again a word that might seem to be
kind of saccharin diversity is really a
by historical standards a major advance
the fact that you don't have to have
unanimity complete conformity within a
culture but there can be diversity
cosmopolitanism cosmopolitanism also
involves just rubbing shoulders with
people unlike you which makes it a
little bit hard to think that they
harder to think they are animalistic
brutish
non-sentient and so on beliefs that are
articulated in many racist ideologies
now they it's not a guarantee that if
you throw people together in cities that
they won't develop these toxic beliefs
but I think it does reduce the
probability I think it's also
significant and this is a curious
feature of idea of dangerous utopian
ideologies that a number of historians
of genocide have pointed out which is
that many of the genocidal ideologies of
the 20th century have been staunchly
anti
they have been they have envisioned a
golden age that involving a return to
the country living in harmony with the
land this is true of Nazism which
demonized the cities and Jews of course
were residents of cities that sought to
empty German cities and return the Volk
to a to the land that's why Hitler
invaded Poland is to get Laban surround
room for Germans to return to the land
as farmers this is true of mouth' insane
collectivization scheme of Pol Pot
emptying the cities and forcing people
into the countryside there's something
about the vision of people living in
harmony with nature and not being
corrupted by the unruly chaos and mixing
of the city that appeals to the
totalitarian indeed genocidal mindset so
cities cities are definitely a
liberalizing force yeah well as a
survivor of the 60s and 70s when Wendell
Berry would basically evoke Thomas
Jefferson wanted the gentleman the
yeoman farmer farmer hated cities been a
lot of city hating in the various
romantic thinking from Rousseau on yeah
right through you know the early hippies
all went to the countryside and got
bored and came back
but there was a real dedication that you
know and we admired mouse communes for
pete's sake and backyard steel mills and
dirt foot doctors and you know I don't
let my contemporaries forget how wrong
we use subjects well the other and the
other dimension historical dimension to
that is that many of the great ideas of
the Enlightenment sprang from the salons
and coffee houses in cities especially
Freeport's Amsterdam London Boston Paris
wasn't a major ocean portal had lively
intellectual discourse but democracy and
cosmopolitan ideals not coincidentally
come from the would it cause mahvelous
the yeah the polis oddly enough here we
are in a city having in San Francisco
yeah was the president of the nation
just down the street that's interesting
so okay it's a year later you're not
doing volume two of this book I'm sure
what are you working on now
question oh you're asking yourself if
anything the pressure is even real and
then people ask me can you write a
shorter version of it can you condense
now that I'll listen this long version I
will make the argument that he will not
make is one is this is so unwelcome an
argument for a lot of people that he
needed to have all of the you saw just a
glimpse of the stories and the data and
the graphs and all that stuff but also
just the analysis line by line page by
page chapter by chapter is so good that
it is a complete argument and it I think
it takes a big book to make an argument
this profound this mind-changing
complete humble opinion thank you what
are you working on now something
completely different my next book
project will be a style manual based on
based on modern linguistics and
cognitive science now that we know more
than we used to about the workings of
language the workings of the human mind
as it processes language can we turn
that knowledge into advice on how to
write more clearly and stylish Lee so
what's the news here you did the
language instinct quite a while ago you
focused on language in a number of your
books so what's different what's the
news that you've got that we all need to
hear you mean what will go into this new
book yeah well three three main sets of
ideas one of them is the just the
mechanics of human memory and attention
as we work our way through a sentence
what said what sentence structures ease
the listener giving the reader give the
reader a sense of a elegant flowing easy
to understand a sentence and that
involves things like the waxing and
waning of memory load the choice of word
and construction depending on the point
you are in a story and and other details
of cognitive processes a second is it
would be a multi-level process the mind
is doing what it's doing all that stuff
yes absolutely that's right every
there's parallel computation and at the
level of sound of course even when you
read we all sound out words even the
skilled readers syntax semantics the
meaning of a sentence and discourse the
flow of an argument or story and and
those are all working in parallel and
exchanging information back and forth a
second is what is your conception of
what you're doing when you're writing
and anticipating that someone is gonna
read what you're writing it's a very
it's an artificial situation Here I am
you know in my study joint a petite a
petite app and then years later someone
who I've never met
it's going to be picking that up and I'm
have this vain hope of exchanging ideas
for that person so how do I since that
is impossible
what is the model that I should have in
mind of my reader and of the process of
communication John Steinbeck wrote all
of his novels to his father and just
took the dear dad off the beginning
interesting he had a very specific
audience in mind and other writers I
know often do that that they have a sort
of ideal reader that they wanted to
tickle their fancy and persuade them and
make them allow for a lot of it is I
think that's that that is a profound
part of the writing process but moreover
I mean this is an idea that I'm going to
adapt from Mark Turner and from C Noel
is that the the mental model that you
should have of your father or of your
friend is that you are calling their
attention to something in the world that
they can see with their own eyes if
their attention is we're only properly
directed to it that is the overarching
conception of one one ought to do when
writing good prose they argue I think
there's a lot of been as many
implications and that's an idea of
theirs that I'm going to run with and
then the third is how do you make sense
of questions of usage and style
if someone says if I say oh that roller
coaster really made me nauseous and
someone said no no you've made an error
it has to be nauseated because nauseous
means causing nausea not experiencing
nausea you say what the hell are you
talking about I've never heard anyone
use it they say no no that's what's
correct you've just made an error
I say well if I'm making an error then
99% of the people under the age of 75
are making the same error so how can it
be an error they said no no trust me it
really is an error how do you make sense
of that kind of debate which the various
language mavens and nitpickers and
smartypants will always make but at the
same time recognizing that there is a
point to correct usage I mean when when
george w bush used the word
misunderestimated there is a sense we
also are all stupid and then we all
thought a pretty interesting word well
there's a sense of you know there is a
resistance you can really say that
that's an error or that is a divisive
policies vulcanize our society now that
that really is wrong now granted it
could catch on maybe the hundred years
it could be right but now we can say
that it's wrong so how do we make sense
of this very strange entity called
grammatical correctness that no one
legislates that can change over time but
that any given slice in time has some
norms that that a careful writer ought
to respect so the third part of the book
is how should a careful writer make
sense of this strange phenomenon of
correct usage they have to read a lot of
contemporary stuff first art yeah yeah
so let's leave the audience with
something that you've probably
experienced which is maybe then we'll go
to wherever they go and and so how was
Pinker's talk well he says that violence
cruelty and injustice is going down and
whoever they talk to will say that can't
possibly be and so there's a resistance
to this news and I don't know if it's
resistance to good news we're weird
about that or that we've made such an
investment in the fear and the you know
these are the worst of times the most
violent century all this kind of stuff
or what it is what do you think is the
structure of the opposition to your
thesis the opposition would be well one
one line of opposition would be the
capacity that is as long as nukes exist
we can't be called a non-violent society
robert jay lifton for example leave that
argument a second is just you wait
just you wait yeah yeah either how long
should and the just you wait objection
takes two forms one of them is the cooks
with nukes mmm it's a matter of time
before terrorist cell will will invent a
nuclear bomb in their garage the other
version is remember a hundred percent of
men have thought about killing somebody
yes but they're very few of us have
actually done it which shows the
essential role of self-control and
inhibition in conduct of everyday life
Freud was right about that the ego and
the super-ego really don't don't leave
home without it okay but the other the
other version of that objection is the
climate change global warming resource
Wars of the future hmm we're gonna run
out of water we're gonna run out of oil
ocean levels will rise inevitably people
will kill each other and people have
been wrong of calamity colors have been
wrong and wrong and wrong and wrong and
keep on calling calamity so what are we
dealing with here
well they're two dimensions one of them
is will there be these shortages and I
and you write that all of the
predictions of resource shortages have
all been shown to be wrong and not movie
will there's there is a climate change
and I suspect that that manmade climate
change will cause a lot of misery and
waste
I don't don't think there's certainly
not skeptical about climate change but
what I am skeptical of is that climate
change will lead to an increase in wars
I mean can lead to plenty of a misery
yeah I was I was wrong the opening
chapter to my book whole earth
discipline I said climate change is
gonna lead to a lot of war data is in I
was wrong the climate change is not
leading to a lot of war no I mean it
could lead to it could be lead to a lot
of bad things but they don't necessarily
include war because there's another
thing you don't appreciate until you
look at the the historical record and
statistics but
not only the complicated statistical
studies that try to correlate climate
stress at time one like droughts in
Africa with civil war at time two most
of the studies find little to no
correlation and which is not to say that
you know the droughts and famines should
be a high area of concern they obviously
are people die they shouldn't die it
doesn't necessary that wars are fought
over them and when you think about it
there unless you have the there is a
paranoid view that all wars are fought
over resources they're just very they're
hidden by the great conspiracy and was
really about tungsten and you know that
co line of thinking if you put a long
stone tungsten yeah it does they I had a
professor in when I was in college who
insisted that it was really all the
tungsten a lot of tungsten I'm gonna see
that's what they forget ideology it's
not you know communism it's not
democracy it's not containment it's all
tungsten I'm telling you it's tunston so
and there are people who believe that
every war is over oil or tungsten and so
on but if you look at what historians
say it's actually not that easy to find
wars that are fought over resources was
the wars are fought over cosmic justice
over here over a revenge over ideology
but there aren't a whole lot of wars
where there was some finite resource
essential to to societies and they they
amassed their armies to see you
controlled it I mean think about it yet
now I'm not not obviously about that
you know world war two World War one
anyway so it's both individual salient
cases and the statistical studies show
there's a loose at least in the past a
loose correlation in the recent past a
loose correlation between resource
stress and arm organized armed conflict
there could be local skirmishes there
could be neighboring populations that
that
you know that pic at each other but in
terms of getting an army out that tends
not to be what wars are fought over now
of course that could change but so far
that's that's not fought over yeah okay
go ahead that's one prediction keep an
eye on what else then there's their
various ways of there have been
objections that a number of my
statistics have been on a per capita
basis that maybe if you looked at
absolute numbers that should be the
appropriate target of our moral concern
mm-hmm the answer to which is first of
all the numbers have gone down in
absolute terms as well as in per capita
per capita basis at least say since
nineteen 246 the sheer number of people
killed in wars has gone way down even as
the world's population as has has more
than doubled but also it really is per
capita basis that is the intelligent way
to assess likelihood of violence in
different eras we're getting a lot more
capitis there's 7 billion going on to 9
billion and then probably level off yeah
and there is that and the intuition is
well would it be right to say that we're
living in more peaceful times if the
number of acts of aggression stayed
constant but there were just more and
more people that seems like cheating the
answer is no it's not cheating because
if there are more people there are every
person born means another person who has
the potential to be a genocide ulm a
niak a hot-headed teenager a rabble
rouser a old lady who puts arsenic in
her husband's tea the number of
perpetrators has to grow every time a
person comes into existence if as more
and more people populate the earth that
somehow the number of acts of violence
remain constant something very
significant has been going on that
prevents all those extra people from
doing what their ancestors did and
with a certain probability into killers
and rapists and and so on but again that
having been said all those statistics
that consisted of zeros mean that even
if you look at the absolute number of
people it's been going down I get a
sense that there's work to do but what I
love about your book is it shows how the
work can keep going forward thank you
for it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you